Schwarze löcher stellen uns immer noch vor große rätsel besonders faszinierend aber
gleichzeitig rätselhaft sind die sogenannten strahlungs jets das sind gigantische
materiestrahl quasi heiße gas fontänen die von schwarzen löchern ins weltall
Gefeuert werden bisher wusste man nur dass die vorgänge ihrer entstehung komplexer und sehr gewaltig sind jetzt ist einem britischen forschungsteam das
unvorstellbare gelungen einen blick mitten in das innenleben dieser jets wie das genau funktioniert hat und was uns dieses forschungsergebnis für
das verständnis von schwarzen löchern bedeutet jetzt bei klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Sich ein genaues bild von einem schwarzen loch zu machen ist gar nicht
So einfach alles was ihnen zu nahe kommt wird verschluckt vorher aber sammelt sich die materie in der sogenannten akkretionsscheibe
einer schnell rotierenden scheibe und genau diese akkretionsscheibe
schießt gigantische materie strahlen aus vielen schwarzen löchern heraus
Senkrecht nach oben und unten ins all und das sind die sogenannten jets die man sich tatsächlich vorstellen kann wie fontaine
Forschungsteams vermuten schon seit längerem dass die jets wohl aus nickel und eisen bestehen und mit
unglaublichen
200.000 kilometern pro sekunde ins all schießen das sind zwei drittel der lichtgeschwindigkeit
Unklar dagegen wie genau entsteht ein solcher jet warum wird ein teil der materie reflektiert und senkrecht ins all geschossen
Jetzt ist einem forschungsteam von der universität southampton aus großbritannien ein spektakulärer einblick in diese rätselhafte
materie strahlen gelungen möglich wurde das durch den röntgen satelliten new star der nasa und mit hilfe von teleskopen auf der erde
Sie interessierten sich bei ihrem untersuchungen vor allem für die helligkeit ausbrüche in zwei systemen
Der milchstraße hier stoppten sie die exakte zeit und stellten dabei fest die ausbrüche sind zunächst
Im röntgenbereich zu sehen er ist eine zehntel sekunde später
Im sichtbaren bereich des lichts und das britische forschungsteam hat auch eine erklärung dafür
schnelle teilchen in der nähe des schwarzen lochs strahlen die röntgenstrahlung aus das sichtbare licht
Dagegen entsteht ihrer vermutung nach
ausnehmen jazz zwischen diesen beiden punkten
Sehen sie den haupt beschleunigungs bereich ist eine größe also die entfernung zwischen diesen beiden punkten ergibt ihren berechnungen nach etwa
30.000 kilometer und das absolut frappierende das haben beide
untersuchten systeme gemeinsam
Das ist schon ziemlich verwunderlich wenn man bedenkt dass ihre zustände und abmessungen sehr unterschiedlich sind
Doch die astronomen astronom sehen die masse der schwarzen löcher als entscheiden dann diese trägt dem aktuellen
forschungsergebnissen zufolge
mutmaßlich dazu bei wie groß der haupt
Beschleunigungs bereich in einem solchen jet ist heißt also konkret
Um so mehr masse gegeben ist umso größer ist der jeweilige beschleunigungs bereich dazu einer der beteiligten forscher
Post an die wir sind hoch begeistert weil es so aussieht als hätten wir einen charakteristischen
maßstab für das innenleben der jets gefunden dieses ergebnis passt tatsächlich zu früheren untersuchungen an
supermassereichen schwarzen löchern auch hier hatten forschungsteams einen zeitverzug festgestellt und auch hier
schlussfolgerten sie auf einen entsprechenden größeren beschleunigungs bereich wenn er kein video mehr
Zum thema schwarze löcher und zu den neuesten erkenntnissen dazu verpassen wollt dann drückt man hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit und dafür draufklicken
Mysteriös schwarzes loch wirft theorie über schwarze löcher um und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran